lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
familiarizarnos con el concepto de
intervalo y también pensar en diferentes
formas de mostrar un intervalo o la
anotación de intervalos aquí tengo una
recta numérica y digamos que quiero
hablar del intervalo que va de menos 3 a
me interesa este intervalo que estoy
iluminando y todos los números que se
encuentran entre menos 3 y 2 pero si
quiero ser más precisa tengo que aclarar
si el intervalo incluye al menos 3 y al
2 o no los incluye o si incluye sólo a
uno de ellos si quiero incluir a menos 3
y a 2 voy a rellenar un punto en cada
uno de ellos esto significa que el menos
300 son parte de este intervalo y a eso
se le llama intervalo cerrado
les estoy mostrando cómo se expresa esto
en la recta numérica con puntos rellenos
hay varias formas de expresar
matemáticamente este intervalo digamos
que esta recta expresa los valores de x
así que puedo decir que estas son las x
que se encuentran entre menos 3 y 2 aquí
tengo mi x esta x va a ser mayor o igual
que menos 3 y además va a ser menor o
igual a 2 noten que la x es mayor o
igual que menos 3 lo que nos dice que x
puede ser igual a menos 3 y también nos
dice que x es menor o igual a 2 por lo
que x puede ser igual a 2 y esto es un
intervalo cerrado otra forma de expresar
un intervalo cerrado sería usando
corchetes el intervalo cerrado aquí está
mi corchete entre menos 3 y 2 y cierro
el corchete esto es corchete nos indican
que se incluyen los límites el corchete
del lado del -3 nos dice que esté menos
3 es parte del intervalo y el corchete
nos indica que el 2 también está
incluido en el intervalo en algunas
ocasiones se encontrarán una anotación
más sofisticada x pertenece a los
números reales tal que y pongo estas
llaves aquí que nos indican que es un
conjunto de valores nos dicen que es el
conjunto de todas las x que pertenecen a
los números reales está en extraña es la
letra griega épsilon y nos indica que
pertenece en este caso a los números
reales tal que o tales que esta línea
vertical significa tal que x es mayor o
igual que menos 3 y es menor o igual a 2
también lo puedo escribir
de esta forma x pertenece a los números
reales tales que x pertenece o es
miembro del intervalo cerrado en donde
incluyó a los límites ambas notaciones
son formas de expresar o denotar el
mismo intervalo vamos a hacer más
ejemplos dibujemos otra recta numérica y
ahora dibujemos un intervalo abierto
para ver las diferencias ahora queremos
los valores entre menos uno y cuatro que
estoy resaltando aquí pero no quiero
incluir ni al menos uno ni al cuatro por
lo que será un intervalo abierto noten
que aquí tengo círculos abiertos arriba
tenemos círculos cerrados lo que indica
que se incluyen los límites aquí abajo
los círculos están sin rellenar
indicando que no incluyó los límites
entre menos uno y cuatro por lo que
menos 0.9 9999 está incluido pero no el
menos uno y también que el 3.9 99999
está incluido pero no el 4 cuál será la
anotación para esto podemos decir que x
pertenece a los números reales tales que
x sea mayor que menos 1 pero no indicó
que sea mayor o igual porque el menos 1
no está incluido en el intervalo menos 1
es estrictamente menor que x y x es
estrictamente menor que 4 no es
pero igual porque no estoy incluyendo al
4 esta es una forma de expresar lo
también lo puedo expresar así x
pertenece a los números reales tal que x
pertenece al intervalo menos 1,4 pero no
voy a usar los corchetes porque estos
indicaría nunca se incluyen los límites
aquí no los vamos a incluir así que
ponemos paréntesis los paréntesis nos
dicen que no vamos a incluir los límites
y este es un intervalo abierto
y quizá ustedes se pregunten bueno aquí
arriba ambos límites incluyen y aquí
abajo no se incluyen los dos límites
pero qué pasa cuando quiero incluir un
lado del límite pero el otro no puedo
hacer esto la respuesta es claro que si
veamos un ejemplo pongamos otra recta
numérica y hagamos algo de espacio ahora
vamos a escribir lo primero y después lo
pondremos en la recta numérica
estamos hablando de todas las equis que
pertenecen a los números reales tales
que menos 4 es menor pero no está
incluido que x y x es menor o igual que
menos uno no estoy incluyendo al menos
cuatro pero si incluyó al menos uno x no
puede ser igual a menos cuatro por lo
que aquí pongo un círculo sin rellenar
un círculo abierto pero x se incluye al
menos uno así que aquí pongo un círculo
relleno un círculo cerrado y tenemos
todo lo que está entre ellos
si quiero escribirlo con esta anotación
lo pongo x pertenece a los números
reales tal que x pertenece al intervalo
de menos 4 y menos 1 pero sin incluir al
menos 4 así que ponemos un paréntesis de
este lado pero si incluimos al menos 1
así que ponemos un corchete junto al
menos 1 y así queda en esta anotación
hay otras cosas que podemos hacer con la
anotación de intervalos vamos a hacer
más espacio por ejemplo todo entre un
intervalo excepto por un valor veamos un
ejemplo hagamos una recta numérica aquí
vamos a hablar de todos los números
reales a excepción de 1 incluimos todos
los números reales pero excluimos el
número 1 ponemos un círculo abierto acá
y continuamos incluyendo todos los otros
valores
como de notaríamos esto podemos decir
que x pertenece a los números reales tal
que x no sea igual a 1 x es un número
real cualquiera pero no una otra forma
de denotar este mismo intervalo es x
pertenece a los números reales tal que x
sea menor que 1 ó x sea mayor que 1
podemos escribirlo así o podemos hacer
algo más interesante esta de la
izquierda es la anotación que yo usaría
por ser la más corta pero podríamos
hacer algo más sofisticado como x
pertenece a los números reales tal que x
pertenece al conjunto que va desde menos
infinito hasta 1 sin incluir el 1 o
equis pertenece al intervalo que va
desde 1 sin incluirlo hasta el infinito
positivo cuando hablamos de menos
infinito o infinito positivo siempre
ponemos paréntesis a su lado ya que
nunca podemos incluir todo
valores hasta el infinito así que el
intervalo tiene que quedar abierto al
menos de ese lado pues el infinito
continúa por siempre y por eso usamos el
intervalo abierto también noten que no
estoy incluyendo en 1 así que x
pertenece a ese intervalo o a este otro
indicando que puede ser cualquier valor
excepto 1 aunque la verdad yo prefiero
esta anotación que es más pequeña